don't think
just do
tell me what you see smoke in the air
[Music]
smoke in the air smoke in the air hang
on
[Music]
here comes another one
splitting the throttles
coming around
what the [ __ ] was that
hang on we gotta get low the terrain
will confuse his targeting system
here he goes
where is he
he's still on us
[Music]
pilot [ __ ] brace yourself
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
it's not over yet
one last chance you can do this
yes
math i got the radio on outstanding get
us in touch with the boat copy that
[Music]
oh my god
where the hell is this guy
he's on our nose
damn it we're out of ammo
smoke in the air boost your flares
that was close
we're out of flares man
[ __ ] he's already on us
[Music]
ah this is not good
[Music]
altitude pull the ejection handles the
second i tell you
there's no other way
eject eject he checked
rooster pull the handle eject it's not
working
[Music]
i'm sorry
sorry guys
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen this
is your savior speaking please fasten
your seat belts return your tray tables
to their locked and upright positions
and prepare for landing
hey hangman you look good i am good
rooster
i'm very good
i'll see you back on deck
turkey status almost there man almost
there
where's my laser i'm sure there's
something wrong with this laser [ __ ] did
i did i did i come on guys
[Applause]
away
[Applause]
miracle number two
now they're in coffin corner we're not
out of this yet
here it comes
radar warning spoke in the air phoenix
break right emergency jackson dagger
three defending
another one
everyone defending
rooster status
[Music]
reserve
deploying countermeasures
negative contact
daggerwood defenders
talk to me about required phoenix big
oh defending i'm out of flares rooster
maybe
i can't shake them they're on me
[Music]
anyone see him does anyone see him
dagger one come in i didn't see a
parachute we have to circle back
you